giant freaking robots do it again
they've released a story suggesting that
Henry Cavill could play Will Riker in
Star Trek 4. Star Trek 4 that will now
apparently be a next Generation reboot
so just like they did with the original
three parts of a original series reboot
they're suggesting that the next
generation will be the basis for Star
Trek 4. unfortunately though it's not
true giant freaking robot where they're
trusted and reliable sources are full of
[__] and it's just nonsense
mainly because JJ Abrams is
contractually obliged to create contact
exclusively for Warner Brothers and also
even though this Star Trek 4 was
announced briefly and you can go back
and check my other videos on why that
happened it was then almost immediately
canceled